there is so much to talk to you about
isolation and kovat 19 but the most
important question for you is is Malcolm
going to become a killer like his dad
well I of course cannot give that away
because that is the ultimate question
for the finale and we may find out in
the finale
I never released a promo of Malcolm
pointing a gun rather viciously and
talking about killing someone so yeah I
mean that's ultimately the question for
Malcolm has always been that is he
capable of that can he can't he do that
and in this instance with the someone
threatening his family and killing his
loved one I think he's pushed to the
limit and we'll see how far that takes
him okay now to the second most
important question where are you right
now
who are you quarantined with are you
good how is life are you going nuts I'm
not too bad I'm quarantine with my
fiancee and who would be my wife now if
not we were gonna get married around a
week ago but of course I'm in New York
as well so that obviously got jettisoned
but but that's a party and you know
we'll do it again in a year we're very
happy to be together and we're in Los
Angeles and we're lucky we have a house
with a with some outside space and and
there's always something to do when you
own a home so I've been keeping myself
busy with different chores around the
house and I've actually just recently
bought a lot of climbing equipment to do
my own tree trimming but I must not have
kindly provided me with some with some
climbing equipment and earning up on my
knots right now music in the trees was
there any discussion between you guys
because you're not the only ones who
have had to cancel a wedding because of
this was there any discussion about okay
why don't we just figure out a way to
get married and then we'll do the party
and everything afterwards was that a
conversation at all I I mean really um
the main reason to get married would
have been so that my field to get on my
healthcare because we are in America
right that's that's honestly was the
biggest worry
it was like ah crap now if she can't get
my health care so but I'm but we've
ended up purchasing other health care
but we you know it's it's a party we're
not breaking up like we had lots of
friends of ours who were just like oh
we're so sorry and it was getting really
annoying like what do you mean like
we're still together we and we're gonna
be together forever and we're getting
married next year it's Leslie we have
our health and hopefully everyone he was
going to make the journey to New York
and can do it next year and we and
honestly we we had gone through
different stages with it we were like
okay well our parents aren't going to be
able to be there but we'll still do it
and then as the week's went on were like
okay this isn't gonna happen and it was
just really about our relatives and
people who are of a certain age or have
health issues who you know we care about
them and we wanted everyone to be there
and have a good time and not be worried
about what could happen so hopefully
we'll be in a much better position a
year from now when did you shoot the
finale and was the finale like so many
other shows affected by shutdowns
because it covered
we um you know we got really lucky
Michael Sheen who plays my dad had to
leave to do another project so we shot
the last two episodes 21 what was gonna
be 21 and 22 before 19 and 20 and so we
had the last two episodes so what the
writers did we were shooting I think
it's just started no we hadn't even
started we're about to start 19 and the
writers very quickly wrote some
interstitial seems that that could put
into 18 and 21 to stitch the gap and and
it worked and amazingly we have a finale
which is really exciting and shocking
and and entertaining and that will air
on Monday so we we got kind of lucky in
that respect I can't imagine not being
able to shoot your finale of so many
shows have been and and just kind of
letting the show tail off it's kind of
how the writers strike was all those
years ago where what if shows just had
to end because they couldn't get it done
so we feel very fortunate and with that
and very hopeful that it will help us
get a second season
how good of a secret keeper are you
because I can only imagine that you out
you must have friends and family that
are as obsessed with this show as people
you've never met before so how good of a
secret keeper are you to the people who
expect secrets I'm pretty good I spent
three years on the walking dead and that
show is like super secretive and I had a
code name and like there was a people
died on that show every year and
obviously you know who they are and you
have to stay quiet about it and you're
answering questions all the time where
people are just trying to get it out of
you so I'm pretty good at all that that
stuff now and actually we didn't have to
wait so long with prodigal son because
the air dates were pretty soon too when
we had been shooting it whereas Walking
Dead was a lot longer wait until the
secret was out there and especially now
actually with with their season they
were unable to finish their finale
episode as far as the post-production
goes so and actually that was one of the
first things I thought which is like oh
my god I'm sure someone dies in the
finale and everyone has to keep that a
secret now for even longer which is a
real pain actually speaking of death
ease death was a was a huge shock how is
this gonna affect Malcolm moving forward
do you know uh well yeah I mean in the
last episode that aired it was a really
interesting scene with Keiko Teresa and
and my character because normally
they're used to looking at their bodies
and talking about it in a funny way and
like really interested way and I thought
once I read the scene I thought wow this
is so interesting that this is the first
time you've seen Malcolm with a dead
body of someone he knew and I thought it
was really nice that a dresser is just
being normal a dresser you know chit
chatting and talking you know about
burritos or whatever and and Malcolm is
in a completely different headspace and
she realizes that that was a really nice
moment and that was the first time
you've seen Malcolm with their body of
someone he knew and I think it really
affects him because I think that's the
first person that he's really opened up
to you outside of his family and his
therapist in a long time
and let into his home and gotten close
to you so I think if he if he could be
any more
damage that might have damaged in a
little bit more and I did then you'll be
in another relationship for a long time
but ya know that's been a big deal and
and we'll see how he reacts in the
finale
do you ever wonder how much more they
can put Malcolm through ah yes I you
start on that part starts on a very high
emotional level by virtue of his father
being the serial killer and those scenes
they have together but then yeah they
really throw Malcolm through the through
the mill and and just me as an actor and
being number one and the cauchy and
coming in every day it's 5:30 starts and
8:30 finishes and you're just you're
just on the treadmill every day and then
emotionally as well
so it was a lot um it was a lot Tom
Payne tears mixed in with some Malcolm
tears along the way budding and I love
the cast and crew and and I couldn't
gotten through without the wonderful
behind the scenes and the amazing
scripts and just everything it was it's
it's a lot of fun to do so and yeah I'm
very very proud of it when it is so
taxing on the character but also so
exhausting for you who has to play that
guy through some of this at the end of
that long day when you go home how
difficult is it to just get to normal or
have you figured that out yet I mean
what I I mean there really isn't a
normal I so ostensibly I was living in
New York and it was like oh how's New
York and like I don't know
I barely barely see New York you know so
it was it really is a bit of a machine
during the week and it's as soon as you
get home you collapse into bed and try
and eat some food and then the weekends
are just kind of preparing for the next
week so it is a bit of a treadmill and
you're fully into the character I was a
bit jealous of Bellamy who plays my mum
who just was going to theatre shows and
like really like enjoying New York but
that's what I'm there for I'm there for
the work and and the work is for very
fulfilling in itself so but yeah I it's
just you know it's a treadmill and what
fans were
no is what are the are there any sort of
details on a season two what's happening
we don't know yet
and obviously this whole situation that
we're in right now has upset the
applecart for many different shows and
and Warner Brothers who produces the
show has a bunch of different shows to
think about but we're we're hopeful and
confident that we have a good chance and
I think I mean honestly hopefully it's
going to be in the next few days that we
hear because the finale airs on Monday
and I think that would be a good time to
announce it so fingers crossed and
before I let you go between this show
and Walking Dead are there any other
stories that you would like to put
yourself through absolute hell to bring
to any sort of screen you seem to have a
type I I think I mean I've said if this
show goes on for a while I'd like to
maybe be behind the camera a little bit
more and and bringing other stories to
the forefront and not necessarily being
in every single scene of them by having
a more behind the scenes approach and
I'm I'm interested in that and started
to develop a few things now